IT'S NOW TIME FOR #WARS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Chris: THAT SLIGHTLY WEIGHTER
FART THAT YOU HEARD MEANS THAT
IT' STILL SHART ON COMEDY
CENTRAL WEEK ALL WEEK LONG.
WE HAVE ONLY LOST HALF OF OUR
ADVERTISERS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THIS
GOING.
LAST NIGHT WE DID SHART CELEBS,
WHICH DELIGHTED ME TO NO END
TO SEE THAT TOP TREND ON
TWITTER.
LET'S DO IT AGAIN.
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#SHARTBOOKS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE HARRY POTTER
AND THE CHAMBERPOT OF SECRETS.
THE GIRL WITH THE DRAGON SHAT
POO.
OR 50 SHADES OF BROWN WOULD BE
ANOTHER WAY TO GO WITH THAT.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK STARTING
NOW AND GO.
YES ROB BUEBEL.
>> ATLAS SHRUGGED AND POOPED
EVERYWHERE.
>> POINTS. OWEN.
>> SUPER FUDGE.
>> POINTS. YES, HUEBEL.
>> DIARRHEA NETICS.
Chris: POINTS. ROB RIGGLE.
>> A TALE OF TWO [BEEP]
>> YES, EXCELLENT. POINTS.
OWEN.
>> HEARTBREAKING DUMP OF
STAGGERING GYROS.
WRITTEN BY DAVID SMELLS LIKE
EGGERS.
>> Chris: OKAY, YES. VERY
LITERARY FOR THIS CROWD.
BUT EXCELLENT, I'LL GIVE YOU
POINTS ANYWAY. ROB RIGGLE.
>> ALL QUIET ON THE WESTERN
GRUNT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ROB.
>> TO KILL A MOCKING TURD.
Chris: YES, POINTS.
RIGGLE.
>> LORD OF THE FLIES AROUND THE
DUMP I JUST TOOK.
>> Chris: YES. I LIKE THAT THERE
WAS ONE LORD OF ALL THOSE FLIES.
>> MINIONS, GATHER AROUND.
Chris: ROB.
>> MEET [BEEP] ONE DAY.